the European Union is 1 empire
and that's how she behaves
she wants to expand further and further
even though countries don't want that like the Netherlands
and as a population indicates very clearly
we don't want that
yet it happens
yet they want to do that
because they want to get bigger and bigger
even if so I said then
in that referendum campaign
if we sign this suspicious
we have literally said several times
we have a good chance of war with Russia don't do that
so everything that was said came true
and so is the European Union
with this kind of expansion piece on collision course with Russia
so also very unwise
and yes it is indeed impossible to comprehend that it is happening
with European Union Just wants to get bigger and bigger
becoming more and more powerful
I think that's behind it